what if i told you everybody eventually
quits yes you what if i told you
everybody including you including
everybody the guy that you admire
everybody eventually could would you
believe it let me make my case soon if i
make my case unit make sense
give it a thumbs up comment below and
subscribe to the channel so here's what
i mean by everybody quits you know
you know how when you were a kid and
you're building this lego and you're
looking at the thing you're like man i'm
i miss one piece and i screwed this
whole thing up i can't believe i did
this and you sit there and you hit a
wall where you're like there's no way i
can figure this out five minutes later
10 minutes later 20 minutes 30 minutes
later you figure out the one piece that
you did you move it you put it in then
everything works out and you go back at
it 30 minutes later the piece is over
you're like freaking sick i was able to
put this piece together as 3000 pieces
whatever right or you're a kid you're
playing a video game you're like i can't
get past this level final fantasy or
whatever this game is you're playing
that's an rpg or technical game i can't
get past this monster i can't get past
this level i just can't do it you're so
annoyed you quit but you come back you
try again you try again you try again
boom all of a sudden you beat this guy
you're like 13 years old i can't believe
i did this pretty sick i can't believe i
figured this out so you didn't quit you
figured it out okay so you say you know
i don't know if i can edit at this level
i don't know if i can sell at this level
i don't know if i can speak at this
level whatever your trade maybe whatever
it is you're doing you hit something
where you say i don't know if i can
figure this part out it's intimidating i
don't know if i can do it
then you figure that because you didn't
quit you eventually got there right okay
so how many times have you figured
something out that you thought was
intimidating that something that was
impossible i'm never gonna figure this
out how many times have you done that
before how many times have you
done something that at one point you
didn't think you had the capabilities to
figure that part out how many times and
why did you figure it out and how did
you figure it out did you figure that
because you kept trying different angles
until all of us are like dude this is
not as hard as i thought it was you ever
done something that at one point was
hard
and now you do you're like this is a
joke like this is ridiculous how easy
this is right
so eventually the same happens with
people in their industry whatever
they're doing they go here like um i'm
good oh my god it's so tough i figured
out they go here oh there's no way i'm
going to figure it out they go here so
no i'm going to figure it out eventually
you will quit using that same muscle
that helped you crack through whatever
challenge or whatever new skill you're
having a hard time learning eventually
you're going to get to a level that
you're going to be content with that
level you've reached and your muscle of
trying to figure it out before like
there's no way i'm going to stop until i
figure this out eventually that goes
away and by the way by the way
he said come on pat there's no way
everybody could i'm telling you people
at the highest level just because a
person is like a boss of a 50 people
maybe he quit understanding what it is
to work with different personalities to
get him to leading how 100 employees
will be or 200 employees or 400
employees or a thousand employees so
he's like he's good enough for 50 or
she's good enough for 25 or he's good
enough to do certain things at this
level and he's content with the results
he's getting and he doesn't realize
the same attitude of never quitting that
helped him get to that position if he
continues with that attitude there's
three four five six seven eight nine
levels ahead of him that he can get to
but will only happen if he goes back and
digs in and remembers what it felt like
to not quit until you cracked the code
to get to the next level very annoying
i'm telling you very annoying because
i'm a byproduct of 20 years every time
not thinking i can get to the next level
and at one point i'm like screw this
next level i'm content i'm like no we
got to crack this code i know you
cracked it kind of like
this is actually cool this is actually
interesting but hopefully for you
i hope you're not yet at the point that
you're quitting to upgrade to the next
level yes you m maybe you're a little
content right now you need to hear this
message
hopefully this kind of pissed you off a
little bit and inspired you to say
i'm done quitting at this level maybe
i'm going to go 10 more levels before i
quit great keep continuing to figure out
how to get to the next level anyways
having said that i did a video seven
years ago titled
10 reasons to never give up if you've
never seen this video click here to
watch that video and if this video gave
you inspiration and some value give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
[Music]